- [Voiceover] Hello
grammarians, hello Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi, David.
- [Voiceover] So, today we're
gonna learn about hyphens.
And what a hyphen is, it's
a little stick, like this,
as opposed to a dash, which
is about twice as long.
And people confuse them a lot,
but they have very different functions.
So what a hyphen is used to do
is it's used to join two words into one.
- [Voiceover] All right.
- [Voiceover] So, for example,
we have the word yellow.
That's a word with meaning.
We have the word green.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- [Voiceover] And we may
have a word that does
fit right in between those two
or two at once, like
chartreuse or whatever.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] You know,
but not everybody wants to
use the word chartreuse.
- [Voiceover] No, it's kinda crazy.
- [Voiceover] Kind of a wacky word.
So, instead of doing that,
you might just wanna say yellow-green,
and connect yellow and
green with a hyphen.
So yeah, so a hyphen is
joining these two things.
But let's say we had a sentence like,
"Her hair was yellow --
green were her eyes."
You know, and so we're still separating
the words yellow and green with a stick,
but a dash is longer,
and instead of uniting yellow-green,
it's separating them the way
that you know, a semicolon might.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it's not one thing,
it's she has yellow hair and green eyes.
- [Voiceover] If she
had yellow-green hair,
that would be a different story.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- [Voiceover] So what's neat about hyphens
and what's kinda confusing about hyphens
is that whether or not we use a hyphen
indicates how common a compound phrase is.
So, Brian Gardner in Gardner's
Modern American Usage,
and in the Chicago Manual of Style
draws this distinction
with compound words.
And I should first say what
a compound word is, right?
A compound word is two words
smacked together somehow, right?
So, if we take the...
so once upon a time, at the
dawn of the Internet page,
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] when
dinosaurs walked the Earth,
and I was just a wee little baby,
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- [Voiceover] you would refer
to getting on line, right.
And then, as it became
more and more prominent,
and more and more popular,
this is what's called an open compound,
then it became on-line,
separated with a hyphen.
This is what's called
a hyphenated compound.
- [Voiceover] Makes sense.
- [Voiceover] And now,
when we think about it,
it's just an adjective, and it's online,
and this is a closed compound.
- [Voiceover] Right, okay.
It became closed, cause
everyone knows what that means.
- [Voiceover] Right, so you
would use hyphenated compounds
when you're kind of in
this intermediary stage
of acceptedness.
- [Voiceover] So like, maybe
one day, in the future,
yellow-green will be a super common color.
Right, it's everyone's favorite color,
so it'll just be smushed
together with no hyphen.
- [Voiceover] Today is not that day.
- [Voiceover] Today is not that day,
so there's a hyphen there.
- [Voiceover] Right, I
think it's also important
to hyphenate for clarity.
Let me explain what I mean by that.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] So, first of
all, when I say hyphenate,
that's just a word that means
to put a hyphen in something.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- [voiceover] To hyphenify.
So if a compound word could be
misconstrued or misunderstood,
you just throw in a hyphen or
check a dictionary or a style guide.
So, okay, so, Paige.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- [Voiceover] I would like
to raise some chickens.
- [Voiceover] Good idea.
- [Voiceover] So, in order
to raise some chickens,
I need a chicken coop, right.
- [Voiceover] That is, yeah, true.
- [Voiceover] And a coop, right, C-O-O-P,
is a place where chickens live.
It's like a little enclosure.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] But let's
say I wanna buy this coop
from a community-run business, right,
what's called a cooperative
business, or a co-op.
Well, now sometimes it appears like that.
Like that, like C-O-O-P, but
if I said something like,
"I wanna by my coop from
the co-op," like that,
it'll end up looking like this.
- [Voiceover] I wanna buy
my coop from the coop.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Or my
co-op from the co-op, or
co-op from the coop, or something.
- [Voiceover] So, in order to be clear,
it really helps to
put in that little hyphen.
And that's the difference, right.
So you're using this to say,
oh, you know, this is actually
short for cooperative,
you know, cause it's operated
by a bunch of people working together,
as opposed to this word,
which is just C-O-O-P.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [voiceover] So you wanna hyphenate
for clarity when you can.
- [Voiceover] Makes sense.
- [Voiceover] So let's bring
all this together, right.
So I made a yellow-green
coop with the co-op.
- [Voiceover] Okay,
you all worked together
to make a yellow-green coop.
That's pretty cool.
- [Voiceover] So we're connecting
yellow and green with a hyphen.
We're connecting co-op with a hyphen
to differentiate it from this word coop.
And that's basically
what you use hyphens for.
You can learn anything, David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.